décryptage avec vos bilal tarab et
bonjour by la largeur sur la situation
dans l'est de l'ukraine et plus
spécifiquement celle de la ville de
severodonetsk on vient d'en parler de
plus en plus critique elle fait penser à
celle de marioupol est ce que nous
serions là dans une situation de guerre
de siège dans les russes sont coutumiers
absolument philo mais on peut même
parler d'un d'une stratégie typique de
l'armée russe on peut aussi ajouter
grozny en tchétchénie alep en syrie
mario paul évidemment et maintenant si
aveiro donetsk alors pourquoi cette
guerre de siège bien parce que quand une
guerre éclair ne marche pas et on se
rappelle que grozny à l'époque était
censée tomber en 48 heures que kiev
était censée tomber en une semaine est
bien quand une guerre éclair ne marche
pas l'assaillant passe sur une formule
de guerre de siège pourquoi parce que
pour lui c'est plus sûr et c'est plus
économique plutôt que de s'enliser dans
une ville avec des chars et on sait que
l'armée russe structurellement dispose
de beaucoup de chars et bien il vaut
mieux pour l'assaillant restez à
distance et bombardé une ville à
distance en attendant et bien soit sa
reddition soit sa destruction complète
comme comme ça a été le cas à marioupol
c'est pour ça que les ukrainiens depuis
plusieurs semaines réclament à cor et à
cri l'envoi d'armes lourdes puisque ces
armes lourdes contrairement aux javeline
aux drones turcs dont on a beaucoup
parlé ces armes lourdes sont les seuls
qui sont capables de briser un siège ou
de repousser un siège il ya eu des
livraisons de canon m 777 au windsor de
fabrication britannique par les états
unis le canada ou l'australie il y a eu
l'équivalent envoyé par la france les
canons caesar calibre 150 mm porter une
cinquantaine de kilomètres et il y a
tous les pays européens mais
anciennement soviétique qui envoient des
des roquettes grad
les russes et les ukrainiens se
préparent à une guerre longue bilal et
nous prennons on n'hésite pas à parler
de guerre d'indépendance
oui il ya un paradigme si vous voulez en
ukraine qui a complètement changé depuis
alors d'abord l'annexion de la crimée en
2014 mais surtout depuis cette invasion
se souvient que depuis le début de son
indépendance en 91 l'ukraine bascule est
constamment au gré des élections entre
un gouvernement qui était plutôt
pro-russe et un gouvernement qui était
plutôt nationaliste ou souverainistes la
révolution de maidan la révolution
orange pardon en 2004 une restauration
pro-russe avec victor ianoukovitch en
2010 puis la révolution maidan il y a
toujours eu ce balancier la l'invasion
russe pour les ukrainiens rebat
complètement les cartes le parti pro
russe si vous voulez en ukraine est
devenu complètement minoritaires à tel
point que dans des villes comme karkhiv
que je vais remonter ici il y à une des
russification rendez vous compte du nom
des rues la rue de moscou est devenu par
exemple la rue des héros de cars qui
vivait il ya tout un débat en ukraine
sur le patrimoine l'histoire du pays par
exemple compositeur tchaïkovski du 19e
siècle né en ukraine et il l'ukrainien
ou est il plutôt de culture russe on a
entendu bilal ces derniers jours des
responsables l'ukrainienne de premier
plan accusés
vivement les occidentaux de ne rien
faire face à la russie ils n'ont
strictement rien fait a même dit le
ministre ukrainien des affaires
étrangères demi trop cool et bat en
l'état actuel des choses qu est ce que
les occidentaux justement peuvent faire
ou aurait pu faire de mieux alors il
faut remettre ses déclarations dans leur
contexte nitrique ou les baux accusé
précisément l'otan de ne rien faire
contre l'invasion russe et dont ce
discours qu'il adressait au forum de
davos ils réclamaient ce que je vous
disais tout à l'heure l'envoi urgent
d'armes lourdes en ukraine alors 7 cet
index pointés sur l'otan peut signifier
deux choses et là on part dans les
hypothèses la première qui est la plus
logique c'est que vous voyez que l'armée
russe si vous voulez cherche à conquérir
ce qui reste du dombass sous contrôle
ukrainien c'est la zone jaune ici pour
vous donner une idée de l'intensité des
combats il y a une semaine l'ukraine
contrôler encore 10% de la région de
luhansk moins d'une semaine après ses 5
% donc c'est vous dire que la russie
avance très très vite donc il y a ce
doit me sur l'otan pour livrer des armes
lourdes à l'ukraine mais il ya aussi
peut-être et ça c'est la seconde
hypothèse un vent de panique qui souffle
chez les dirigeants ukrainiens
puisqu'ils sont peut-être en train de se
rendre compte que finalement ils vont
perdre non seulement le dombass mais
tout le sud de la crimée où on distribue
des passeports russes ou le rouble est
en circulation est de se dire que dans
des conditions éventuelles de fin de la
guerre peut-être que l'ukraine veut
faire en sorte que l'otan accepte son
intégration dans l'alliance pour la
prémunir d'invasion russe futur